the global emergency declaration on
January 30 and that was declared based
on experts opinion I think we declared
the emergency at the right time and when
the world had enough time to respond
that was WH Oh director-general former
Marxist revolutionary we gave you that
expose the other night Tedrow siddhanam
Gabrus who just today offered his
defense of his handling or of course
miss handling of the corona virus
outbreak now this comes about a week
after President Trump put a hold on the
funding for whu-oh which is great news
given that organizations complicity in
China's kovat cover-up joining me now
exclusively is our Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo mr. secretary thank you for
being here tonight
earlier this week I said that the global
community should demand that Ted Rose
and his cronies resign in order to just
get this behind everyone what's the
state of play regarding our relationship
right at this moment with the w-h-o
Laura thanks for having me on first of
all as you said the president has
stopped all US taxpayer funding for the
World Health Organization it's
completely appropriate given the recent
history but Laura you've got a
sophisticated set of viewers they'll
remember this isn't the first time that
the World Health Organization has failed
to do what it needs to do when that
pandemic begins to break out in fact I'm
very worried that we're still not
getting it right so well you recounted
what happened in January and the delayed
announcement about the pandemic and the
fact that China had asked them not to
announce and the World Health
Organization didn't do that but even
today the Chinese government hasn't
permitted American scientists to go into
China to go into that only the Wuhan lab
but wherever it needs to go to learn
about this virus to learn about its
original look we know it began in one
but we need to figure this out there's
an ongoing pandemic we still don't have
the transparency and openness we need in
China and it is the World Health
Organization's responsibility to achieve
that transparency they're not doing it
they need to be held accountable and
what's been great is the other countries
around the world to begin to recognize
the WHL failures as well and this is an
opportunity mr. secretary for the United
States to take a leadership role given
the closeness that the w-h-o has with
China which spends a lot of fraction of
the money we've been sending to the
w-h-o so given all of this given
everything that's happened
shouldn't Tedros be called on to resign
before we go forward at all in a
relationship with the w-h-o i think
we've got to take a real hard look at
the whu-oh and what we do coming out of
this Lord we reformed this back in 2007
so this isn't the first time we've had
to deal with the shortcomings of this
organization that sits inside the United
Nations we need a fix we need a
structural fix for the whu-oh if we're
talking about real accountability here
the guy who's leading the organization I
don't see how he can be part of the
solution so tonight you're not ruling
out that not that might be one of the
requirements for going forward with the
w-h-o you're not ruling it out no I
think that's right
Laura even more than that it may be the
case that the United States can never
return to underwriting to having US
taxpayer dollars go to the WTO we may
need to be have even bolder change than
that yeah make our own organization
right mr. secretary Senator Tom cotton
wrote a phenomenal piece in The Wall
Street Journal yesterday saying that the
US government is investigating whether
koba 19 came from a government lab in
Wuhan evidence is circumstantial to be
sure but it all points toward the Wuhan
Labs well China
absolutely disavows any culpability from
that lab as does the chief scientists
world renowned scientist who runs that
lab she said the same thing in
interviews over the last week do you
agree though that this is what the state
of our information now is that this lab
was the source of the virus that has
done huge damage and loss of life in the
United States Laura we don't know
precisely where it started that's that's
the core problem China kicked out
journalists when the United States under
President Trump tried to get in
to conduct the very investigation that
needs to still be undertaken it still
hasn't been done when we tried to do
that the Chinese denied access that only
to the lab but to the wet markets to all
of the places that one would need to go
to identify the original source for this
virus we're still trying to get that
information we're still seeking
transparency your predecessor I know you
guys are texting pals john kerry claims
mr. secretary that we need to entangle
ourselves even further with china going
forward watch we have to work with china
you have to work with China on Kovan 19
on all pandemics you have to work with
China on the security challenges of the
region you have to work with China on
cyber and cyber warfare right now I
think the president is all over the
place and even heading in the wrong
direction on cyber warfare we have we
have to work with China secretary Pompeo
we got we're getting drones from China
to spy an American citizen some of our
mayors and localities but John Kerry
says let's keep it going I'm not sure
where to begin or other than to say the
president Trump has taken a
fundamentally different view with China
than President Obama did and secretary
Kerry did whether it was the unfair
trade relationship the president's
attempting to untangle whether it's
being serious with China that says when
you conduct cyberattacks against us
we're not going to tolerate that and
here even in this we'd love to find a
way to cooperate with the Chinese
frankly on all of those things but it
takes it takes a partner who's willing
to do that and as you describe the
biggest threat isn't our ability to work
with China on cyber it's to make sure
that we have the resources available to
protect ourselves from Chinese cyber
attacks these are the kind of things the
president Trump is taking seriously and
we we have to make sure that we
recognize the challenge that China
presents to America and work with them
where we can well I have to ask you in
closing mr. secretary about a tweet from
President Trump earlier today he said
I've instructed the United States Navy
to shoot down and destroy any and all
Iranian gunboats if they harass our
ships at sea now this came after a
and had successfully put into orbit what
is called its first I guess its first
satellite military satellite hours
before this tweet so where do things
stand at this hour is that's a pretty
serious threat coming from the United
States and what's next
it is pretty serious it's a coincidence
you asked that question right about
talking about John Kerry or will call
when under the Obama administration with
secretary Kerry they took 10 of our Navy
sailors and John Kerry apologized to get
them back this is a very different
approach from our president he takes
seriously the obligation to protect our
forces wherever they may be in this case
on naval ships in the Arabian Gulf we're
gonna do everything we can to make sure
we defend our folks and continue to
deter the Islamic Republic of Iran you
know Laura last thing to say they
launched this military satellite today
they had promised that their entire
satellite program their entire missile
program was civilian and the person who
oversaw this launch was general Hodges a
day this the same fella whose Corps
forces shut down an aircraft killing 176
innocent civilians just a few weeks ago
how comfortable are you dealing with Kim
jong-un's sister if for any period of
time she becomes the leader of the
country going forward given the concerns
that some are expressing about Kim Jong
Un's health right now mr. secretary well
I did have a chance to meet her a couple
of times but the challenge remains the
same the goal remains unchanged whoever
is leading North Korea we want them to
give up their nuclear program we want
them to join the League of Nations and
we want a brighter future for the North
Korean people but they've got to
denuclearize we've got to do so in a way
that we can verify that's true no matter
who's leading North Korea all right mr.
secretary thanks so much for spending
some time with us tonight we really
appreciate this man thank you Laura